when do you start writing everyday about
11 o'clock I usually roll out of bed and
have my routine we're all you know say
some prayers might've take a little bit
not much read the news see what's going
on and then pack up and you should go
over the coffee shop and start writing
so but I'm also a night out too so I
stay up late writing so it's it's
sporadic them because I'm usually
working juggling like four or five
different things at one time so I'm kind
of hopping usually hopping around to
make sure I'm kind of on top of whatever
needs to be done first how long are you
writing for um it sounds often - pretty
much all day I mean you know I'll be up
late watching TV but still have my
laptop on writing a little bit so you
know I it depends if I have a writing
assignment and I'm I'll be more
structured in it in far that I'll make
sure that I focus on that and then try
to like have fun didn't have a life the
rest of the time that I'm not writing
but if I'm in a stage where I'm like
working on four or five different things
trying to get them off the ground then
I'm just I'm usually writing quite a
quite a bit so you go to the coffee shop
do you ever write here I'm a partner
sometimes but if I stay here I get very
distracted like it's you know I want to
watch TV I want to take a nap you know
I'm very comfortable here so I like to
go up to the coffee shop cuz I get my
socializing done too because I you know
have friends there and stuff like that
so I like to get out and do that as well
there's a lot of regulars there that we
have - yeah yeah there's a lot of them
so thanks a lot of writers do they ask
you what you're writing on or no one
really asks that they just kind of know
people yeah people will talk to you and
especially if you go there a long time
and you've made friends with people they
they kind of know what you're up to and
you know they follow you on social media
in your time on stuff they'll be they'll
ask you about what you're doing and
things like that so yeah it's it's a
pretty it's fun it's you know it's very
transitory though - because there's a
couple of regulars but you know a lot of
the writers will you know if they moved
and they'll go to another coffee shop or
they'll go work it like the WGA has a
you know space to work at or people like
rent spaces now which I'm actually
they're not doing because I think I
broke it down and some I forgot what the
place is called but there's a company
where
you can like over in a space an office
base and Cameron Bure any of these names
but I did the math and it's like oh well
for the cup of like a Starbucks coffee
and done it every day
I could actually rent this place for a
month and they have free coffee all day
but I I drink tea so no I have to check
to make sure they have tea it's not as
good as starving no no but it's like
it's a cool like you can get like a desk
and like a shooter do you have your own
little spot so it you know it does if
you're actually leaving your place to go
to work it does kind of put you in a
different mindset because even if I'm
walking in Starbucks
even on time no I'm going there to work
it's like I'm gonna see my friends I'm
gonna you know be distracted and you
know you never know what's gonna happen
so it's it there is some definitely some
wisdom to having like it's a writing
space that's like an office you know so
that's that's kind of I'll do that at
some point I haven't done that yet but
you know I'll have a place where I'll
have like an office that's just a
separate you know building aside from
where I'm you know where I'm living
right yeah I was always opposed to
coffee shop writing for the longest time
and then I noticed that if you have
headphones on and you can still sort of
see what's going on around you it
actually is invigorating yeah yeah
whatever you're working on even if
you're not screenwriting you're just
working on something right yeah
headphones oh they're important because
there's people just comes here talking
to you oh that's true yeah it's a good
buffer it's a good social buffer yeah
but also libraries too I mean I'm just
surprised that actually it does feed you
and I was opposed to it for the longest
time and I I can tell now why people
need to get out of the house because you
got a you're you need that little segue
from being in your home to your brain
going hey we're going to work now it's
hard to you know if I'm just going for
my bedroom to the living room it's hard
to just sit over here and say okay turn
on my work brain because I'm like wait
what's on TV and I'm gonna take a nap
really quick and yeah right or if I see
an interesting article on like Flipboard
or pocket or something and then I'm like
let me just read this and then and I'm
distracted so yeah once you get to rail
then it's kind of right you had to work
you get the focus back again would you
say you're very disciplined when you
know that you need to get these four
things done that you're pretty good
I think my friends think I'm more
discipline that I yeah like I think I
could probably more disciplined I I do
work hard though but it's it's um I
guess I am I guess I am but in my brain
I'm not disciplined enough and my
friends like you're so disciplined I'm
like yeah I feel like it'd be done more
if I was more discipline but I'm usually
always juggling a lot at the same time
so but you always always want to make
sure you don't have more on your plate
than you can like really dedicate
quality time to so I've definitely
learned the art of saying no as I've
gotten over because when you're young
you want to say yes to everything
because you think oh this could be my
you know these three opportunities could
be the only thing I things I ever get so
you're always like saying yes to
everything and as you get older you
start realizing like you know it's okay
to say no to stuff if you're not
passionate about it or if you don't
think you'll have the time to to really
do it and I've done that where I'm like
this early isn't my thing and I don't
think I'm the best writer for it so you
know I know a lot of writers that will
take you know jobs just to have a job in
MLS I think it's something that I could
do justice to I'm not going to take it
on as a as a job unless that's a
challenge sometimes there have been
things where people have brought me
projects where I'm like this isn't in my
wheelhouse but it would be really fun to
try to write it so then I'll do that but
it's got to be something that really
strikes a chord with me do you know any
writers that write 8-10 hours a day yeah
yeah yeah okay so do they usually I'm
assuming they stop for lunch or they do
something yeah yeah I mean yeah I know
that I have a lot of writer friends that
they they do if they're not on staff
there they're very much like they treat
it like a nine-to-five job so they'll
you know get the morning they'll do
their thing a little right to lunch time
they'll take lunch so we're right till
5:00 and they'll stop writing for the
day and that's again that's I think
that's great if you're if you're working
on one thing at a time you have the
luxury of doing that more I think if
you're trying to do two or three
projects at the same time then it's
harder to to do that but you can do it
you know I certainly have friends that
that that do it you know
you